as we pause to reflect on the events of
20 years ago and the heroes who
tragically lost their lives we would
also like to take this time to celebrate
those who serve and protect our
communities daily particularly
throughout the coba 19 pandemic
joining us on field this evening
as you see before you
dozens of local firefighters police
officers and paramedics from king pierce
and snohomish county
religious well here at home at 273 era
in the home ballpark this will be his
27th appearance 11-5 record 150 one and
two-thirds 103 strikeouts over 32 walks
for flexon two out two on first inning
david peralta coming to bet
peralta hits it through the infield tell
martay coming around third diamondback
strike first it's one nothing a pair of
walks and a two out rbi by the freight
train here's the next offer swinging a
ground ball up the first base line right
there fair in front of the back france
has it takes a half step back hits the
bag for the out on smith that's going to
retire the side ferto castigano's 23
year old right-hander can he be part of
the long-term solution in arizona he's
hinted this year that he can but he'll
need to rebound after a rough one
against these mariners last weekend
mitch
tim licker said they watched film for
about an hour after last night's game
there you go that tapework the video
work that may be paid off
two-run homer cha-ching
2-1 mariners
a grinder
again it's going to work his tail off to
get it fixed and now we're in the video
room after the game last night immediate
dividends
exit below 102. center cut fastball
big leg kick gets his foot down on time
that's middle middle for him and it's
barreled up he flexing a little sharper
here in the second edit three two to
beer
nice pitch at the bottom of the zone
nick ahmed shortstop one out nobody on
o2 pick
strike three call
96 on that fastball the 0-2 pitch
swagger of this struggle
two lucky one swinging half some of that
2-1 mariners josh rojas stopped the
order mark and van meter to follow
france
[Applause]
play made at first base
flexing will continue to the bag and
play
really well done as flexing got there in
time
here's the o2
strike three called he froze him burned
it in at 96 at the kneecaps sizzles it
right by van meter and chris flexon is
on his game and now it's mitch hanigar
who hormoned in the first
annika reaches out pops it up nick
almonds underneath that one
away into thirds seeger making him work
still one and two
right by him swinging a miss another
strikeout for seeger he's been striking
out a lot lately more than ever before
in fact
that one leaked back in over the plate
peralta runs it down the freight train
in the gap
and that's out number three
now have a chance to get even or take
the lead here's pavon smith
hanging breaking ball he knocks it into
right field carson is home peralta stops
at third
payment smith we're tied at two
runners are on the corners in a 2-2 game
still no outs here's seth beer the dh
he dunks that one into left field that
gets a run home base hit for seth beer
and it gives the d-backs the 3-2 lead
there they are beers all around beers on
me that's right
three singles and a double for arizona
here in the fourth
high fly ball left field going back
marmillos
shy of the track
is there runner tag goes to third got a
chance oh he's me got him
good job by marmo
david trying to try him but pretty good
throw one hop
nice play by kyle secret third he was on
the base then he decided to get off the
base and go up a little bit try to get a
better hop so now it's two outs of man
at first and here's dalton varshall
dalton varshall hammers one way back in
right field
dalton varshall way out of here that's
his tenth
and it's five two diamondbacks
wow
the kids are all right seth beer last
night dalton varsio tonight
oh that's just a center cut for seam
fastball like hitting off a pitching
machine right there diamondbacks leaded
5-2 bottom of the fourth two down and
here's jared kelden if it swung on it
belted deep to center field marta going
back to the wanting track to the wall
goodbye baseball
it kept going and going out to the pen
and left center field opposite field
shot off the bat of jared kellnick his
ninth big league home run
and i'm telling you that ball had some
carry to it
and it's now the diamondbacks five and
the mariners three kyle seeger the
left-hand batter is the hitter
1-1
[Applause]
breaking ball out to left field peralta
is there and a nice job by castellanos
to strand that lead-off double
back-to-back two-out walks for sheffield
and now varsha will be the hitter
breaking ball into center and that gets
to the wall var shows at it again
here comes beer he will score
ahmed coming around third dalton varsity
has knocked in four
and it's 7-3 diamondbacks
and the batter will be luis terence the
right-hand hitter
swinging a miss
turret's down on three pitches that's
three strikeouts in four batters for joe
and now mantiple will face crawford the
lead offender the shortstop the
left-hand banner
chops that one right at nick ahmed
rawley into third two outs and the
batter is mitch hanigar strikeouts for
henniger have piled up as of late and
there's another one sean poppin gets
that final out and gets us to the eighth
inning so now you're gonna have to pitch
around that ty france 7-3 d-backs by me
stops it to shortstop van meter in front
of ahmed and they can't turn two
one out down for toro
and he sends this out to center for
cattell marte
france back to the bag at first two
ounces in the game just came back at the
tail end of last month
rojas from the outfield grass
elie ramirez works around that lead off
walk
two outs in the
[Applause]
ninth the tapper overshift is on
diamondbacks have the win 7-3 when
delkin shuts the door
you